Rob here with a gamespot news update the  witcher 3 wild hunts latest patch is  available today CD Projekt RED announced  today one point oh eight makes changes  and improvements to the areas of  performance you I gameplay and graphics  specifically this patch as preparatory  features which reads upcoming new game  plus mode but here are our top two  changes listed in the patch notes that's  right it's a patch notes video number  two heads chopped off during finishers  will no longer disappear number one  players can perform a role just before  landing to significantly reduce the  damage caused by falling that's awesome  I shall now demonstrate how garel  previously handle fall damage before  after for all your gaming news you go to  gamespot com